so I was wondering because you have the
horror genre part you have some
technical challenges in this one are
there any past projects of yours that
you found that experience coming in
handy most on this yes absolutely I
think working on a wrinkle in time
really prepared me for this because that
was my first time working with like CGI
and green screens and all the things
that we had to do with wrinkle I think
prepared me for this time really glad
that I got both experiences because they
were so different but kind of the same
with using the technical stuff and being
technical and physical and emotional so
it was great
Lee's action direction is just
next-level firm so many reasons was
there anything you did on this that made
you stop and think like whoa that's the
movie magic required to make that happen
I can't believe it right um I think my
fight sequence with the Invisible Man
even though I had to like really work by
myself and work with myself I didn't
really have anything to work off of um I
knew Lee showed me a little bit of like
what it was gonna look like on screen
and I just thought it was super cool
that he paid attention to detail and
they had like little marks on my neck
like where the invisible man's hands
would be it was just really technical
and really cool what are you looking at
is that one of those scenes where you
have the stunt performer in the green it
wasn't anything I was really working
with thin air and acting like I was
strangling myself and and basically
kicking the air and screaming and crying
it was a whole thing there's not almost
like learning I guess like dance
choreography in a way a little bit a
little bit I mean with the stunts like
throwing myself on the ground like
learning how to do that safely was a
little challenge but I think getting
emotional is it's quite fairly easy for
me oh it was it was fun you got one
moment in this though that I don't know
I don't understand this is why I'm not
an actor I don't understand how you get
yourself in that headspace and then I
don't understand how you shake it off so
please please enlighten me how do you do
that
I just think it's the constant reminder
like me reminding myself that my
characters reality is not my reality and
I have to like kind of snap out of it
and I usually do that fairly easy and
quickly but it's always good to just
like know that you're not going through
what your character is going through
thankfully are you into horror movies in
general I'm trying to get into them a
couple of years ago I was like no way
I'm being a part of that no way I'm
doing that but now they've been so fun
to film and I've been a part of a couple
of them that it's just become natural
and I'd love to see him as well what was
the reason you felt that way was it when
you watch that kind of spooked you out
or was there any other reason I mean I
watched the orphan that was pretty scary
but I actually liked it and I watched
that when I was fairly younger so I was
freaked out about that but then I don't
know what happened after that I was like
I don't want to see anything like that
again but I liked it almost a good one
yeah and then I've been like seeing some
with friends and and we go and have a
good time okay so what's the sub-genre
of horror that you're most into is it
you know action thriller like this is it
slash or supernatural what's your
favorite ooh um I would say the
sub-genre I love the most from horror I
would probably say like a sci-fi yes or
like the psychological thriller is
always cool cuz I love to think and I
love to like be on the edge of my seat
and trying to figure out what's
happening but not being able to is
always rewarding and this is why it gets
in your head for a lot of those reasons
I can't shake it off and that's exactly
what I wanted to be like this yeah I
also want more movies with Elisabeth
Moss in the unsound bull cuz I had
actually just seen the movie that she's
in surely it's Sundance and just
watching her operate within an ensemble
and creating that chemistry he's blowing
my mind I think she's so great she can
you tell me a little bit about working
with her and Aldous because your
chemistry at the very beginning of the
movie is so important so kind of like
grounding the movie and starting that
connection with the viewer so great yeah
it's so good and they're great actors
and to be able to work with them was an
honor but to be able to like create a
barn off screen was great as well
because they're great people
and super humble and super grounded and
they have the best sense of humor so we
had a good time what kind of stuff do
you learn from them or really any other
actor that you're working with as far as
process goes are you ever in a situation
where your print process doesn't line up
with someone's out someone else's and
you have to adjust um no because even if
my props process is different from
others I feel like we're able to like
separate and prepare on our own but also
come together and have a connection
which is great but Elizabeth is an
observer and I'm an observer as well but
she looks out for her not only her
character but everybody else's character
so if my hair was out of place or I was
in the wrong position or the camera was
out of place whatever the case may be
she made sure that it was fixed because
she wants the thing to be as great as it
could be so I want to carry that on to
my other sense I always get really happy
when I hear there's a leader like that
on ascend so how was it working with Lee
because from upgrade to this he's just
he's on another level now and he
impresses me to no end so what is it
like working with him on set and what
can he bring out of you as an actor that
maybe someone else hasn't before yes I
mean he's great he's a great director
but I think he has a deeper
understanding of where actors are coming
from because he has acted before and he
really knows the places that we have to
go to to really execute what we're
trying to depict and really execute our
characters very well um and he just made
us go there he was like no that's not
enough I need you to take it up and it
can be exhausting while you're doing it
like screaming and crying but I think we
all appreciated it at the end because we
know that he was giving the best
performances and all of that was well
worth your while I can assure you that
we need more of you on screen so I have
to ask about two upcoming projects of
course euphoria season two I'm freaking
out about it are we gonna get more of
you in season two yes yes you're right
answer G is becoming her own person and
she's
our own storyline which is very exciting
so I'm excited to start that very soon
so you start shooting it soon as we
start shooting season 2 very soon that
is so exciting good luck with that thank
you also I don't know if you've already
shot your bit of Suicide Squad but James
Gunn is another one of my favorite
directors out there he's incredible like
that nicest person but also SuperDuper
talented and I have filmed my my piece
in Suicide Squad too so I can't wait to
see that all come together and I was a
fan of the franchise before so now to be
a part of it is really cool
have you seen birds of prey yet I
haven't I've been so busy but I want to
go see it there you have to go see it
because it'll make you a bit more hyped
for your own movie right margot robbie
is another one that i look at like an
Elizabeth moss just she's so nice her
her leadership in the industry right now
is very special mm-hm
that is awesome though I'm very excited
about this movie for you and everything
coming up thank you so much for your
time today
congratulation you